as we continue to learn more about the
train derailment that took place in Ohio
and we continue to cover it it's harder
and harder to avoid this sub story
that's come up about some breaking
related regulations that were put in
place by the Obama Administration that
the Trump Administration rolled back now
the reason I haven't spoken about that
yet is it's genuinely unclear to me and
apparently to others as well whether
those regulations are actually related
to what took place in this particular
train derailment I have a friend who's a
train engineer and he looked at it very
strongly and he said yes that happened
but it's not clear yet at least that
that's related to this train derailment
but putting that aside for a moment that
topic has now even made it to Fox and
Friends even Fox and Friends who you
know the interesting thing about this
story
is that it has gone somewhat bipartisan
because I mean it's it's kind of crazy
but from some of the right they're
interested in the train derailment not
because they care about trains or they
care about regulation but because they
believe the media doesn't care about the
train derailment because a lot of the
victims in Ohio are white
I know it's crazy and we already talked
about that on the Wednesday show but
regardless it's leading to right-wing
media caring about the train derailment
they also see it as an opportunity to
criticize Transportation secretary Pete
Budaj Edge and Democratic President Joe
Biden so needless to say I have to tell
you I was surprised even Fox and Friends
is Brian kilmead yesterday morning
mentioned this issue of those regulatory
changes right uh speaking of the White
House apparently regulations regarding
train safety well this is Steve Steve
Ducey not kill me change during the
Trump Administration uh this particular
Railroad and others lobbied president
Trump to dismantle an obama-era rule
that would have required railroads to
update their braking systems and
apparently the Obama administration had
pushed for it to govern transportation
of hazardous materials after about half
a million uh barrels of crude were
dumped But ultimately the Trump
Administration undid that and said the
cost exceeded the benefits nobody
understands and you know when they talk
about whether or not it's safe to drink
the water okay so then they get off of
that aspect that is absolutely and
completely true if you Google this
you'll find it widely documented here's
one article Trump rolls this is from
2018. Trump rolls back train breaking
rule meant to keep oil tankers from
exploding near communities and the
article reads trains that carry oil and
other flammable material won't have to
install won't have to install
electronically controlled brakes that
reduce the risk of train derailment and
explosions after the reversal by Trump
officials of an Obama era safety rule
the pipeline and hazardous materials
safety administration posted the rule
change on its website and again they say
today this was from September of 2018
arguing the cost of installing these
more sophisticated brakes outweighs the
benefit this was first proposed in
December 2017 around the time of a
deadly Amtrak derailment and finalized
today the improved brakes had had a 2021
deadline for installation so it is 100
percent true that this was something
that was started during the Obama
Administration a deadline was placed on
it under Trump that was canceled
I would want to be really sure
that it's actually related to this train
derailment before we ascribe this train
derailment blame under that umbrella but
it still goes without saying that we are
not over regulated when it comes to
trains by any means and in fact it's
probably the opposite but ultimately we
will have a more specific answer here
and I mean listen good for Fox News for
bringing it up they get they mention it
as an aside and they get off of it very
quickly but they did bring it up to
their credit
there is something going on with this
2024 presidential primary that should
interest political scientists
psychologists
sociologists it it's unbelievable the
dynamic that is developed between Nikki
Haley who announced her candidacy on
Tuesday against Donald Trump and Trump
himself Trump very quickly jumping out
and attacking Nikki Haley as terrible at
her job Nikki Haley not attacking Trump
in fact not even drawing any
distinctions and yesterday morning she
appeared on Fox and Friends she's been
going around saying we need a cognitive
test for politicians over age 75. now
she mostly means it because of Biden but
she's argued the real advantage to her
over Trump is she's from a new
generation which means she's younger so
in some sense Trump being 76 and Nikki
saying if you're 75 or older you should
take a cognitive test it also applies to
Trump so the Fox and Friends crew asks
Nikki Haley about it and says well how
would Trump do on that test because he's
also of that age Nikki doesn't take the
bait refusing to criticize Donald Trump
how would Donald Trump do on the
competency test if uh at 76 years old
no reason to think he wouldn't do well
this time he identified the tiger it was
great but I do think we need it and it's
across the board I don't think it's for
president I think you look at Congress
look at all the members of Congress you
have to start doing this for elected
officials when people send someone to
Washington they need to know they're at
the top of their game that's why I think
those competency tests are important we
can't have someone like Joe Biden who's
asleep at the wheel and have China
sitting there threatening us and US
wondering if he actually knows what's
going on this is good for America to do
competency tests this isn't about one
person yeah so refusing to criticize
Donald Trump this is the funniest sort
of dance that's taking place here do I
criticize Trump don't I well I am
running against them but I also don't
want to go against them too hard and
maybe she's actually running to be
Trump's VP that's another thing that
occurred to me this is really a campaign
so that she runs a campaign doesn't
insult Trump and then if she does well
enough maybe Trump invites her to be his
running mate I don't know this campaign
is palpably palpable you could just feel
it it's thick it's going nowhere
um in another moment during the same
interview she said
Donald Trump is my friend yeah I mean
it's not in exactly that way take a
listen to this when you flip around
to answer that yeah
well first of all president Trump is my
friend I was honored to work with him in
the administration I thought he was the
right president at the right time and
that remains to be the truth we had a
great conversation I told him that I was
doing this because I thought it was time
for a new generation I thought we needed
to leave the staff I told him you're too
old and we needed to move forward so
I I just don't even know where to start
first of all
is it possible
that Trump actually does
want Nikki Haley to run it is possible
and I keep going back to the same reason
why when you look at 2024 Republican
primary polling when it's Trump versus
DeSantis head-to-head DeSantis does way
better and sometimes is actually winning
when you have a poll that it's do you
want Trump or DeSantis or Pence or Don
Jr or Mike Pompeo or Nikki Haley or
Roger Stone or Alex Jones who have the
more people you stuff into the poll
the better Trump does because a lot of
those other choices take away more from
DeSantis than they do from Trump right
now so one could make the argument Trump
wants as many people as possible to run
because it hurts DeSantis and it helps
him that's a possibility secondly
is there any shot that Nikki Haley wins
this nomination if she refuses to go
head-on and criticize Trump and by
criticize I don't even mean insult I
just mean draw some policy distinctions
right do something to show other than
just being young and a minority and a
woman which is the identity politics
that Nikki played at her first rally
which we covered yesterday which took
place Wednesday
you have no chance and the same applies
to Ron DeSantis but differently with Ron
DeSantis I think DeSantis if he does Run
for the nomination has to abandon taking
the high road because it's just not what
Republican voters seem to want but with
Nikki Haley's campaign if all you're
going to say is Trump is my friend and
you're not going to criticize him in
terms of policy you're not going to
suggest yeah the cognitive test is for
Trump too because he might be lose
you're going absolutely nowhere there's
just no way and if her intention is
really just to be the VP rather than uh
be the nominee then maybe this is the
right approach it's just not clear what
she's thinking we should figure out
is she coming up with these ideas or are
these the ideas of her advisors is she
waiting to transition in the here's what
what is different about me I don't know
the answer but this is already a
completely insane primary we will have
the clips I played for you here
on our YouTube channel youtube.com the
David Pacman show and this clip will be
dubbed into Spanish and available on the
Spanish YouTube channel which you can
find at davidpackman.com
Spanish check it out
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David packman show of course is a
community supported program you can
support the work that we do at
joinpakman.com and it is a lot of work
it really is you know people think oh
David you just sit around playing on
your computer
well yes but there's more to it than
that as well I could tell you someday
you can sign up at joinpakman.com you'll
get instant access to the bonus show and
to all of the other great great things
and of course while I believe our normal
membership rates are eminently
reasonably priced you can take a
discount a non-means test a discount
available to everybody
by using the coupon code 24 starts now
and it really has Nikki Haley Donald
Trump and all of the different things
let's hear from some people in the
audience we love to hear from the
audience ideally through respectful
communication mutually uh uh acceptable
communication why don't we start today
via the Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord with Harry from Columbus Ohio
Harry welcome to the program let's start
with hopefully no technical issues and a
beautiful beginning to today's live
calls Harry go
oh boy
not an auspicious start
Harry muted and just horrifying things
happening Harry you want to give it one
more shot buddy
yep well Harry's having a tech disaster
that's too bad you got to select the
right of audio device for it to work
let's try Ricky from Charlotte and see
if Ricky from Charlotte can help us
recover
um Ricky welcome to the program what's
on your mind today
hey David can you hear me I can hear you
beautifully
okay cool yeah so I wanted to ask you
about this right-wing Civil War that we
see starting to unfold yeah and I'm I'm
just curious I'm not exactly sure like
what the
like what the dividing lines around this
will be I mean I guess we could say like
in the context of going to the 2024
primary it could be the Trump versus
DeSantis line but I'm I'm really curious
about like what the fracture will make
you you know like what the Civil War
will make them look like fractured after
like this whole thing is done and
whether there could be like any sort of
permanent split that could benefit the
left you know what I'm asking a hundred
percent and it's a really hard thing to
predict but it's a really astute thing
to be wondering about because up until
weeks ago really the dividing line has
been you've got your pro-trump and your
anti-trump Republicans fine when the
speaker vote came that ultimately led to
Kevin McCarthy becoming Speaker of the
House you had a further subdivision of
that where you had anti-trump but then
you had pro-trump that likes McCarthy
and pro-trump that says we need an
alternative so it was like Marjorie
Taylor green versus Lauren bobert the 24
election is going to be its own thing
because for example you're completely
right you've got the DeSantis and Trump
part of it but now you also have for
example Nikki Haley Nikki Haley worked
in the Trump Administration she was
Trump's uh ambassador to the U.N but now
she's running against Trump but the
other wrinkle to it is Trump actually
needs as many people as possible to jump
into the primary because if you look at
head on one-on-one polls
between Trump and DeSantis it's very
good for DeSantis when you include more
people in the polls it's better for
Trump because they take away support
from DeSantis so it's weird because
Nikki Haley is a former Trump staffer
who's running against Trump but Trump
actually benefits from the field being
more divided so you're asking a really
great question which is after it all
shakes out then what does it the party
look like and it depends whether Trump
wins or doesn't win if Trump loses the
primary whatever the split is between
now and and July of 2024. if Trump loses
the primary
all bets are off in the sense that there
will be a realignment of the Republican
Party altogether and they might even say
Hey you know we also don't want the
Marjorie Taylor greens get them all the
hell out of here if Trump does win the
primary then there will be a question of
whether the anti-trump Republicans have
had enough and they want to really try
to do something invoking Force Major or
something along those lines it's so
hypothetical Ricky that I don't know but
it's a fascinating question
yeah no I'm I'm really curious to see
where it goes but like my general thing
is I just hope that it causes like
permanent lasting damage at you know I
believe like what Chomsky said that
Republican party is the most dangerous
organization in human history and like
so I just root for their downfall and
it's been really interesting to see how
um some of the infighting that we've
seen you know over the last few years
sort of on the left at least like in the
Independent Media space yeah seems to be
really consuming the right because the
right you know the Republican Party in
the right seems to be like more you know
closely United with their whole like
internet culture and Independent Media
culture so I don't know if you've seen
some of these characters like a Laura
Loomer she's this really crazy fart
right like yeah Nick Fuentes adjacent
I'm familiar um yeah and she's like
going hard again she's like essentially
leading like a trump robust movement for
2024 and they call him DeSantis
essentially calling it a stance it's
like a lefty and all this stuff and the
interesting how about that Ricky if I
may is some of that infighting that took
place on the left it's with people that
we now all know aren't really on the
left like it's so it's so funny to give
a couple examples Jimmy Dore and Glenn
Greenwald I don't know if you're
familiar with them it's funny because at
one point it was sort of well accepted
that they're part of quote the left but
then as the infighting began it kind of
became clear that they're kind of
reactionary libertarian populists really
and and that is not exactly on the left
and now you know Jimmy Dore is doing his
own thing and Glenn Greenwald I think is
on like rumble or something like that I
don't hear anyone on the left still
considering them part of the left
anymore and it's sort of like become
very clear that a lot of these people
really weren't on the left if that makes
sense
yeah I think well yeah I know that like
Jimmy and
there are some others I don't know like
uh Michael Tracy or some of these other
people especially like around the issues
like the Ukraine Wars claim would be
like the true leftist still and I just
think that the interesting thing with
that is and this can be my conspiracy
theory I think a lot of those characters
are were being played by like some sort
of Peter Thiel
um deal you know in order for them to to
get rich and they never really believed
in interesting doing the shift that they
they believed in but I just hope that
like I would love to see the the a
similar thing like that actually
happened to the right because I feel
like it could be more damaging because
that's more tied to their like
mainstream culture than you know the
left independent meaning
because these characters on the right
that are involved in these tiffs they
really are on the right like when when
the Jimmy Dore thing happened it was
like oh this guy's not on the left but
these right Wingers really are on the
right they're it's not like oh you know
it turns out Laura Loomer is actually a
leftist like obviously that's not
exactly so it has the potential to be
much more damaging yeah okay well let's
hope it works let's hope yeah all right
my friend thank you very much
there's Ricky from Charlotte great to
hear from him let's go next to Johnny
from Toronto we will go to our friendly
neighbors to the north Johnny from
Toronto I am inviting you to speak once
you accept and properly configure your
audio device hopefully you and I will be
able to have dialogue
hey David can you hear me I can hear you
fine all right David sir it's so great
to be here I kind of have tears in my
eyes I hope my audio is not too bad but
I just had a quick question in relation
to your workout program okay I remember
a few a few months back you mentioned
that you weren't quite comfortable going
back to the gym I'm back at the gym uh
yes I was just kind of interested and
curious if you've had a workout program
and what that looked like and because I
had a follow-up question to this as well
yeah I mean so so just to make sure I
didn't step on you I I am back at the
gym at this time not literally now right
now I'm in my studio but I mean I'm
going to the gym I basically alternate
forms of cardio between running
elliptical and rowing machine and then
rotate through different weight lifting
elements targeted at different parts of
the body I hit the body with weight
okay got it got it yeah and I I guess my
follow-up question was I remember a few
weeks of probably a couple bucks back at
this point there was someone who uh I
think they left you a voicemail or an
email where they said that oh you're
like a 150 pounds uh I don't even
remember like calling it a data or
something like that and I was wondering
do you think it's kind of a bit of a
humorous question do you think people on
the right might take you slightly more
seriously if you decided to like bulk up
and gain 20 pounds of muscle or
something like that you know I'm not
sure number one because it's not really
that obvious when looking at screens I
don't think and as a counter example I
got word through our team that Ben
Shapiro has been lifting weights and
apparently has put on some some you know
modest amount of muscle and I don't see
anyone taking him anymore seriously
okay I I understood got it
well thank you for the uh opportunity to
talk man I appreciate it all right
Johnny from Toronto thank you very much
uh important questions for sure that I I
I can't can't ignore those types of
questions because they are critical to
the culture War I would say let's go to
Smitty from Los Angeles Smitty from Los
Angeles California welcome to the
program welcome back I think right
you've been on
I have I have good morning David how are
you I'm doing well
great
um so uh uh Ben
um Shapiro has kind of been still in
some of the language that you use uh he
started using on his
shows so I listened
kind of hear what he's saying which a
lot of times is just crap but what
language of mine has he stolen
he's sort of using the phrase you use
where if all you have is a hammer then
everyone looks like a nail
well I didn't invent that to be clear
no but I haven't heard of anybody else
in podcast doing fair fair language and
he he certainly I've been listening to
him for a while because I do like to get
the other perspective yeah and just hear
what
things are trying to get away with
saying but um yeah so I just thought
that was where I thought I would report
that to you interesting
anyway uh I guess my question is today
um
with the book Banning in Florida and
that sort of thing
isn't that something that
teachers could actually Sue
um pseudosanthus over on first uh on
First Amendment grounds
yeah yeah you know I obviously I'm not a
legal expert my formal training is in
dentistry so I I'm a little bit out of
my
um comfort zone here but from what I
have read
it is arguable it doesn't mean you would
win but it could be argued that
if a state government says you can't use
these books or whatever the case may be
that you would have some kind of a free
speech case but you know these things
often come down to I don't want to call
them technicalities but they they come
down to very narrow aspects of the law
and definitions that exceed you know my
ability and it sounds like yours as well
since you're asking about it to
determine that as a layperson it sure
sounds like there could be a First
Amendment argument there
yeah I mean that's what I thought I just
haven't heard anybody I would assume
that somebody would already
be taking him to court over that or
something certain aspects of it but I
haven't heard that yet so I mean listen
what I would be more concerned with in a
sense although obviously if there's
legal remedies that they should be
pursued is that as I said earlier this
week the book Banning and idea Banning
stuff is a prominent characteristic of
fascism and that should very very much
scare us
exactly yeah exactly that's what I'm
very worried about I'm just continuing
to see a lot of signs that
are are not very good I think we're in
for a long fight and we all need to be
diligent in doing everything we can to
contribute in ways we can to prevent
this from getting any deeper I mean I
would I was hoping that
the party would experience a Republican
party would experience some kind of
um
Spiritual Awakening but I don't see that
happen with them yeah the only Spiritual
Awakening they seem to be having is that
they they now are very much in favor of
Christian nationalism I saw a new poll
about that but that's a depressing topic
for a different day Smitty
yeah so I have one thing I wanted to uh
see if I could just uh
um read to you real quick or something I
can tell you about so I had Chad GPT
uh write a song about you you want to
hear the first verse okay yeah sure
he's a man with a mission speaking the
truth with Precision from politics to
pop culture his chosen decision he's the
one and only David Pacman's name and
when he speaks we all listen and the
truth isn't vain I like it first one I
like it very much I would consider it a
success
all right well thank you very much sir
all right Smitty uh sir thank you with
tears in my eyes uh we say goodbye for
today but uh not forever not forever
let's go next to Aubry from Wisconsin
Aubry welcome back to the program if
you're able to get your equipment
functioning properly
Aubry we are connected but I believe you
have the wrong audio device selected
and Aubry last chance to get that
equipment working
well it's too bad
uh there goes Aubry let's go instead to
Keaton from San Jose Keaton welcome to
the program
what's on your mind today
and you do have to unmute yourself
Keaton
hey David can you hear me yes I can
great
um yeah so you had talked about this
during the the midterms
and uh 2020 and I'm
curious as to what you mean
when you say uh Democrats need to be on
the offense yeah
you're that's the you're just curious
what I mean by that
uh yeah I guess strategically
communicatively what what that looks
like yeah so being on defense would be
Republican being on defense is the
status quo basically it's Republicans
make some claim these people on the left
want to make our country socialist or
they want to ruin this or they want to
indoctrinate your kids or whatever and
then Democrats come out and like they
get organized very slowly on their
talking points and then they come up
with something but it's just a defense
and then you sound defensive and
Republicans have already gotten out
ahead on the issue so you're kind of
just playing reactive Politics the truth
is Democrats given the disaster and joke
that is the Republican party where they
don't even pretend to be about policy
anymore the Democrats could put together
a much more proactive strategy
to create and take control of the news
cycle pointing out all the ways in which
Republicans if they got their way would
actively worsen the country for large
swaths of people so there's no it's not
a there's no hidden message it's just
Democrats need to be more proactive
rather than reactive I see
and and one last question sure
um I'm wondering if you
and and the mods or whoever it is are
planning on having another chess
tournament because I I actually found
you through
um
chess.com
Champions I think POG Champs yes well
that was a tournament that I organized
I'm open to doing another chess
tournament we're just so busy and we
have so many different things including
the children's book coming out soon and
others I would gladly do another chess
tournament but it's on a list of many
things that we would like to do if
that's fair
of course all right well uh thanks a lot
David all right Keaton from San Jose
great to hear from you I'm told that
Aubry from Wisconsin's microphone is
fixed let's see if that is true Aubry
from Wisconsin welcome to the program
let's see if we can make it happen this
time can you hear me this time yes I can
Aubry welcome back okay hi David
um thank you I'm So Sorry my phone's
like schizo okay please don't swear
because as as I've told you during all
of your previous phone calls we have to
bleep when you swear for our radio
Affiliates thank you
[Laughter]
I apologize yeah my phone is
schizophrenic I really apologize okay no
I'm sorry don't be mad I can hear it
you're like mad at me right now no I'm
curious what you're bringing to me today
because you do you do Broach interesting
topics yeah yeah yeah okay I was going
to munch into you about like filters and
stuff but I don't want to talk about the
time I wanted to talk about I wanna I
have okay sorry
um what is your take on America and
Israel right because like right now
America and what ethereal
Israel the country of Israel
hello yeah because this happened like a
week ago anyone's rescue this yeah can
you hear me yes I can okay cool cool
okay yeah because this happened like a
week ago and I was like commutered on
your server actually because me and a
certain someone got an argument I'm not
gonna get into it she was very rude to
me anyways um so this like
um happened a week ago they were like
they like um bombed a military
um uh weapons whatever in Iran and like
if this was like any other country this
would start a world war three but you
know because it's sweet baby Israel
America didn't care because you know we
pumped them up with money and I'm a
proud Palestinian Lebanese woman
um as you can see like you know am I pfp
I'm like you know an Arab girl
um so that like you know I just like
want to see your take like do you think
that like America will ever stop humping
Israel's money or do you think that like
you know they're just gonna take over
the entirety of Palestine and you know
do whatever they want or whatever the
heck they want that's what I said I said
hack I didn't say anything
um Aubry you know you've broached such a
massive issue which is the
israeli-palestinian conflict
so I have the right to say it
oh I didn't I'm not questioning your
right I'm just saying I couldn't
possibly
thoroughly respond to what you're saying
in this format but what I do want to
tell you is that I have dozens of videos
with what I believe is the only real
credible path to peace in the Middle
East on my YouTube channel and I outline
it in detail including what I believe
the borders would be what I believe
leadership on both sides would have to
look like
Etc and so I would recommend checking
out some of some of those segments I
think but do you think it's crazy that
they're able to just
probably leave Aubry Aubry Aubry you're
you're swearing completely
uncontrollably okay
let's see if we can simmer the situation
a little bit
um I believe that a two-state solution
is the only likely path to peace I don't
know that I believe current leadership
on either side is credibly going to get
us there and I encourage you to check
out my material on on the YouTube
channel about it
okay thank you all right thank you and
Aubry remind us you're not from Long
Island right
Wisconsin okay very good all right Aubry
great to hear from I appreciate it thank
you have a great day me too there goes
Aubry from Wisconsin let's take just a
very quick break to recover from that
and once we've reconstituted our energy
we're going to come right back and take
more calls so if you are waiting on the
Discord please don't hang up we'll be
right back to it
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's hear
from some more people via Discord at
davidpackman.com
Discord let's go to Kansas where Casey
from Kansas Casey because you're in
Kansas obviously you're really happy
that the Kansas City Kansas Chief won
the Super Bowl right
I don't watch any sports ball oh okay it
was a joke because Trump once seemed to
think that the Kansas City Chiefs were
from Kansas rather than Missouri but it
went over like a lead balloon my friend
I'm sorry yeah he I'm just as ignorant
as him on that fair but no but hold on
Casey you know that Kansas City Missouri
is in a different state yeah you do okay
good all right
okay but uh I just had a question
because somebody was talking you were
talking about like the how defensive and
slow the Democrats are sometimes yes sir
do you think that the Democrats should
just like
stop Focus testing and fixating on polls
entirely like I don't know that
Democrats are what are you in what
evidence do you have that Democrats are
focusing on polls
like in the first six months of Biden's
presidency he was not really doing much
okay and then well he did the Kobe
stimulus right Focus test vaccine
rollout they came up with the phrase
mega mega
yeah they didn't accomplish anything
like he came out and he said oh these
are like mega mega Republicans it turned
out that that was from democratic
advisors doing like Focus testing with a
bunch of you know groups being like okay
yeah this sounds the worst mega mega or
something you know what's crazy is this
is the first I've ever heard that term
uh I think it was mega mega but it might
have been something else no you're right
I just Googled it it's absolutely true
that that was a thing but you mentioning
it is the first I've ever heard of it
but yeah back when this was happening I
was just like it felt like the Democrats
weren't really like doing like an
aggressive strategy for a while then the
first thing that Biden comes up with is
Mega Maga after sitting on a focus group
for six months do you think
that sort of stuff is a problem at all
yeah I mean I think it's kind of I think
it's just kind of a waste you know um
and and here's the thing it's not wrong
to think that the right nicknames for
things can be effective because let's be
honest
Trump got the term crooked Hillary to
stick to Hillary Clinton Trump got a
sleepy Joe Biden to stick to Joe Biden
among sort of so like he didn't take six
months to come up with that well we
don't know we I guess I'm not sure how
long it took him but he came up with it
is the point so I think it's right to
think that messaging and nicknames and
those types of things can can be
important I just don't necessarily know
that focus group testing them is the
right way to go
okay yeah and dude do you think that
they should get new strategy advisors
like entirely well I don't know I mean
maybe yeah it's very easy for me to say
that I think the approach needs to
change it's possible that the current
advisors and strategists would be fine
if they could agree on what is the
different approach going to be I don't
know they want to do that though yeah I
guess no
but yeah that's all I had all right well
Casey thank you for the call I
appreciate it okay thank you there is
Casey from Kansas not Missouri from
Kansas let's go next to Joe from New
Hampshire Joe from New Hampshire welcome
to the program
can you hear me yes I can
awesome I have kind of a two-parter for
you sure uh
you know I'm I'm living on a college
campus right now and I would say it goes
without saying that most people around
here are more political than the average
uh population sure um but even then I
meet probably the majority of people I
meet are would consider themselves
apolitical they don't like to touch
politics interesting
um and I'm noticing a lot of people I
meet just in general seem to think that
like being a political is some kind of
virtue
um
so yeah it's similar to enlightened
centrism there are people who believe
that because they're in the middle and
they're like well listen you know one
side wants to kill trans people and the
other wants them to be able to use
whatever bathroom they want I'm in the
middle it's like you're in the middle of
one position That's crazy dude you know
so I think the enlightened centrism is
similar in a way
um but also now let me say one thing
here Joe before you move on go for it I
don't think that political apathy
is a good thing because political apathy
carried to its full conclusion allows
small groups of extremists to basically
decide how our entire political system
works so I think knowing what's going on
and voting very very important at the
risk of turning people off from my own
program I do think there are some people
who are too sucked in to political
issues and events and news that will
never affect them and that they will
never affect and there are people who
have written about this it's not
nihilism but it's sort of understanding
you know okay what am I going to do
about what's going on in Ukraine or the
South China Sea or and I've seen for
some people it becomes unhealthy where
they're so sucked into news and politics
they're just upset they're not doing and
a lot of things they can't do anything
about it other than I might occasionally
donate to a cause or Vote or whatever
the case may be and so I do think it's
important and I do this myself I think
shows like mine if you imagine like a
pyramid instead of a food pyramid it's
like a information pyramid I should be
at the top of the pyramid sort of like
the junk food you're using this to fill
in your understanding of news and events
built on an understanding of history and
and other areas built on a foundation of
critical thinking and epistemology and
there are some people who are just
constantly consuming opinion and and I
don't think that that's a good thing to
do
yeah absolutely I I definitely agree
um I think my main concern is that
there's a lot of people who uh for
instance in my state of New Hampshire uh
we elected two uh Democratic senators
but we re-elected the the uh
anti-abortion uh Republican Governor yes
and I was talking with some people after
after I I personally voted and uh they
were talking about who they voted for
and they're like yeah you know I'm not
too political so but you know I still
like abortion so I voted for the two
Democratic senators and the and Chris
and Nunu because they thought Chris Nunu
was pro-abortion right and they just
like were not critical of who they were
voting for yes no that's a real problem
and I also know people who are like yeah
I'm not really political but I just I'm
kind of more of a republican so I don't
get very involved or pay attention but I
just vote for Republicans but I'm not
really very political and then I talked
to the person and all of their views
actually really align more with the
Democratic party so sometimes that
apathy is actually more destructive than
people who are involved
yeah that's kind of what I was thinking
too yeah
well Joe I appreciate you breaking
bringing up the issue it's an important
one yeah thanks for taking my call all
right there's Joe from New Hampshire
great to hear from uh why don't we try
oh I don't know maybe Emily from
Colorado Emily from Colorado welcome to
the program
Emily from Colorado I've invited you in
hello David can you hear me I can hear
you fine Emily thank you all right I
hope your day is going well it's going
well thanks
um so lying let's talk about lying uh
politicians have always done this uh
forever but with trump it became this
sort of comical like spectator sport
right and some kind of robot who can't
be destroyed and only gains power
through lies he was President
um but now we have Congressman George
Santos boxing world champion and tallest
man alive yeah among other accolades
um and he's lying a lot and really badly
right and it's about his credentials and
his identity and it's getting a lot of
attention and people are calling for his
resignation but no one's making him
resign no and so my question is like how
is there no way to make him resign I
know a law that says if you lie to the
American people that you're fired
whatever well that would be a very hard
that that law that would be a very hard
law not only to pass but also to enforce
but you're pointing out something
interesting which is politicians have
lied for a long time but there was a
different type of lie that was
normalized by Trump and so before Trump
politicians would lie but most of the
lies were things like you know I lowered
the deficit no you raised the deficit
and it's like well it either went down
or it went up but you could sort of
massage data and figure out some narrow
definition to make what you're saying
marginally plausible where it's not an
out and out lie that type of line you're
saying there was more new ones there was
more Nuance to the lies and they were a
different type it wasn't like oh I I
have a different name and I had jobs I
did right Trump normalized a different
type of lie and the types of lies that
George Anthony devolder Santos has been
telling are the types of lies that were
normalized by trumpism
um
as far as the resignation part I mean
listen Republicans don't seem to want to
force a vote on his resignation and they
have the majority so it's a very tough
situation
right I feel like I I don't know how we
protect democracy from corruption with
this two-party system right and you know
it's a small margin in the house and to
some degree Republicans might be
thinking well if we force devolder out
or George or Anthony whatever you want
to call them all of them if we force
them out
um and then we lose one of the small
margin that we have and then maybe
someone dies or resigns or whatever and
then all of a sudden we may end up
losing control altogether and I think
that that's their primary motivation
yeah yeah it's depressing
it's a huge problem I don't know and I
don't know how we're going to dismantle
the two-party system in America anytime
soon well you've got to do campaign
Finance reform you have to change how
our elections are you know there's so
many things that have to be done
proportional representation would be a
good step forward none none of which are
happening in the next year and a half I
can tell you that Emily no well uh yep
it's frustrating and I'm glad you're
frustrated with me I'm with you all the
rest of it I'm with you I'm with you
thank you Emily appreciate the call
see you later all right there is Emily
from Colorado capping off I would call
it an eight out of ten today as far as
calls are concerned only three bleeps
needed and only two dropped calls which
is really not bad really not bad all
right we'll take a quick break we'll see
everybody very soon and much more coming
up on the Friday show right after this
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
let's get into this week's mailbag email
info davidpackman.com if you have a
question comment criticism suggestion
whatever you also may be featured if you
leave a YouTube comment or if you uh
send us a message on Twitter or Facebook
or whatever the case may be
uh let's get right into it because there
are so many interesting messages I want
to start with a negative message yeah
sometimes we start with something
negative and then we move on to positive
things clay wrote in with a very
aggressive message clay said Gutfeld
kicks every late night fascist ass
maggots ass that's why you whine about
them I can't remember the last time I
mentioned Greg Gutfeld you whine about
vaccines because your dumb asses ran to
pump the clot shot you now you clowns
see that it's killing people and always
the Perpetual victim it's not funny
but at the same time you're all such
narcissistic lobotomized morons you
won't admit your party leaders F to you
because Liberals are idiots now run off
and wait for the impending abortion hmm
I guess I do support
self-aborting liberals this is a sick
person
um I feel so bad for people like this
because their lives must just be
terrible that they talk like this that
they're willing to even send messages to
people like this one was by Facebook you
know it's like you this we can see this
guy's full name and where he works and I
would even if I thought stuff like this
which I don't
I would be
embarrassed into a hole in the ground
if I ever sent someone a message like
this and so I feel bad for these people
I really do it's more of a sad thing
that they are willing to send messages
like this than anything else but they
exist and there are many many many of
them one more criticism this one came
via email from Wayne Wayne said are you
getting your content from MSNBC CNN
you're an idiot y-o-u-r
it's almost a requirement folks if you
send hate mail you have to have the
wrong your your an idiot my an idiot
you're an idiot if you believe any of
this just wait for the speech tonight
not this was about the State of the
Union not one word will be the truth is
the Biden crime family continues to lie
about everything gullible low IQ people
like you is the reason they're slowly
wrong there and then it should be r
instead of is slowly letting socialism
take over our country wake up idiots you
know it's this is this isn't about
bringing being a grammar Nazi it's if
you're accusing me and my audience of
being low IQ and stupid and all these
things
you've got half a dozen grammar errors
in a four-line email and you want to
call me low IQ come on guys and again
it's more of a tragedy it's an
educational tragedy but understand
something is correlating here as I've
said before
if people learn media literacy and
critical thinking early
it's like a vaccine against
disinformation
and it's not a shock that some of the
people who have six errors in a
four-line email
also believe things that aren't true
about everything from vaccines to
socialism to whatever the case may be uh
it is it is not a surprise it's not
being a grammar Nazi it's noticing
there are Trends here all right Bjorn
wrote in about Sarah Huckabee Sanders
response to the state of the union says
hey David thanks for the show I listened
to your show February 8th saying that
Sarah Huckabee Sanders response was
maybe the most vile State of the Union
response you heard to me it wasn't even
a response to the State of the Union as
it didn't really address anything in the
State of the Union it felt like a
pre-recorded Biden is woke and bad and
the left is horrible statement vile yes
a response I don't know what do you
think you know one of the things that
Bjorn is right about and I realized
after the fact
I don't I'd have to listen to it again
I don't know that Sarah Huckabee Sanders
needed to wait until after the speech to
give that speech what what I mean is
she could have recorded the speech
before Biden State of the Union Address
and it would have been just as relevant
Irrelevant in reality because I think
Bjorn is right I don't know that
anything Biden actually said was
addressed yes socialism and woke and all
these different things but I don't think
that the actual subject matter of
Biden's speech was addressed by Sarah
Huckabee Sanders I think Bjorn is
absolutely on to something it really
wasn't an actual response Matt Rhoden
and said David sir I love the new
backdrop on the set you're the best Matt
you know I have to tell you
um
on this program
anytime we've changed anything
if we're lucky half the audience is
positive about it when we change music
we get so many criticisms when we've
changed set elements we get criticisms
when I went to oh you know now I do wear
a tie on the show now I'm no longer
wearing a tie now I'm not even wearing
the the Blazer I'm back this it's always
negative Our Guest hosts negative of
which we'll get to by the way this
change to the backdrop which I believe
is a beautiful change has been received
more positively than anything we have
ever changed on the show which is great
makes me happy you love to see it and
we've got a couple other small changes
up Our Sleeve which will be coming soon
nickel wrote to me and said David
there's something that bugs me when you
cover George Santos in your show you
keep referring to him as George Anthony
devolder kitara Santos I think you
should not include Katara at this point
what he did in his past as a drag I
think he I think Michael means as a drag
queen was not a lie and he doesn't know
any explanation about it to anybody I
know you're not asking for that but when
you keep including that part when
covering his continuous lies you make it
look like that's a lie too it wouldn't
be a big deal unless homophobes
transphobes and drag phobes could use
that against him which I'm afraid can
happen that's why I think you should
limit his name to George Anthony
devalder Santos already long enough
without Katara so I have two thoughts
about this number one Katara is related
to a lie because he said it wasn't him
initially when the photos came out of
Santos and drag which is politically
relevant because Republicans have been
on a crusade against drag queens and
drag shows and drag time reading hour
whatever
um he lied and said that wasn't me and
then later said actually it was me so it
is part of the lie that being said I've
received emails on both sides of this I
received a few emails like what Mickel
says which is it could be sort of seen
as like mildly homophobic or drag phobic
or whatever to include Katara in the
name because that was his drag name and
others who wrote to me including people
from the LGBT community who said David
he lied about the drag stuff it's
completely fair to include Katara when
you say George Anthony Katara devolder
Santos sort of like Stephen Kenneth
Destiny Bonnell II
I have stopped using Katara over the
last week
I don't have a strong feeling one way or
the other
but certainly nothing homophobic is
meant by it
John wrote in and said if Trump is still
president why does it matter that the
election was stolen seems like it
wouldn't matter right great job David
and Luke keep it up that's from John who
also goes by Mongoose yeah this is one
of those you know
the January 6th riots were actually
totally peaceful and the rioters were
antifa and it's like wait but so were
they peaceful or were they antifa
um it is true it is true that for the
people who say the election was stolen
and also I believe Trump is still the
president if Trump is still the
president it wasn't really stolen was it
if you believe Trump won good luck
speaking to these people I mean it's
like you're trying to apply logic to
claims that are completely illogical
so while you're completely correct I
believe it would be a waste of time to
try to confront these folks with that
but probably entertaining on some level
Daniel wrote in about my Replacements my
guest hosts and said David none of these
people comes even close to you I cannot
watch the show if you're not there
please don't go away again says Daniel
well Daniel I'm sorry to tell you I'm
going to continue going away breaks are
important vacations are important now
we've gone over this issue with the
guest hosts many time with you in the
audience there was a time when when I
was off there was no show just there
were no shows and a lot of people didn't
like that they said David you should
have someone fill in for you
we started having people fill in which
by the way is a lot more work for us
um and no matter who fills in
I get a ton of emails saying I didn't
like that person people write in they
say I don't like when Luke Beasley fills
in I prefer farron we have Faron people
write in farron's terrible you should
have uh uh you know Jesse dollamore or
someone else Jesse dollar more fills in
for me Jessie's terrible he yells too
much someone said you should have Luke
do it there is not going to be a perfect
fit but I think there's a couple
takeaways from this number one it is
flattering that me being gone is
upsetting to people in the sense that
there are people that are sort of
counting on the show and like the show
enough that when I'm not here it's
upsetting to them I I find that
beautiful I think that that's a
testament to the community that we've
built here and it's a really great thing
now where it get cycle is the people who
threaten to cancel their memberships if
I have replacement hosts or go on
vacation you know
if you're telling me you value the show
so much that you want me to be here more
and you're willing to pay for a
membership it seems a little strange
that you would say I'm going to stop
watching and cancel my subscription if
you take any vacations it seems not only
insensitive to the reality that like hey
I need breaks too
but if you love the show so much that
you're Furious when I'm gone why would
you swear it off and start supporting
the show that's a little bit of a bummer
but here's the bottom line nobody likes
not everybody likes any of the hosts
that we have okay and after all it is
the David packman show so it sort of
makes sense that at least in general
you're tuning in to see me
so I'm very sensitive to that we are
going to continue a rotating cast of
guest hosts that way there will be
hopefully someone everybody likes and if
you only want to see me then just don't
watch or listen on the days that I'm
gone I think that's the best solution
for everybody and most importantly I
really appreciate everybody who does
have a paid subscription and when we're
off writes in and says hey David just
wanted to let you know I'm a paid
supporter you being gone reminded me how
much I I like the show and count on it
enjoy the time away can't wait to see
you when you're back those are really
beautiful messages I get like three
whenever I'm away okay uh we have a
great bonus show for you today sign up
at joinpathman.com we'll see you